honestly
2003 this is super impressive
killed him dude so andrew is this a
example of a good vfx shot or a bad vfx
shot in your opinion here
thanks to vessi for sponsoring this
video stick around to see how you can
save 25
off your first pair hey what's up guys
we are back
with another vfx artist react episode
and we got andrew kramer joining us
again for the second time if you guys
don't know who andrew kramer is you've
been living under a rock especially if
you're into vfx he is
the reason that i have a job and he's
the reason a lot of you guys might have
a job too if you're in a superintendent
of vfx this is the 15th anniversary of
video co-pilot and
we're excited about some of the new
software development things that we've
been working on just good to be here and
hang out and check out some other
people's hard work not all of it's hard
work
sometimes we just play smash brothers
oh okay yeah yeah let's go ahead and
jump in with some clips here
oh she's like something's up
oh they don't quite have their hdr
reflections down yet they're not bad i
guess
okay okay
solid cg smoke there oh heck yeah
which cemetery green lit this like you
could just drive the car through a
cemetery it's like grandpa's
grave it'd be an honor
this guy's walking and they're tracking
the skeleton onto
him there's not much to track there and
yet it's pretty good
for a moving figure so i wonder if he's
walking and then does he just
duck out of frame so they only have to
clean plate a few frames after that
i bet he's entirely from a different
shot in rotoscope and paste it in you
know the thing that stands out to me
and this is a huge challenge with like
shiny reflective stuff that they did a
really good job with in t2
for when it was made but look at how
bright his sweater is before he
dematerializes there and look at how
dark the reflection is on the top of
the chrome head even there once it goes
more chrome the reflection's still
darker than his sweatshirt
implying that the shiny chrome is less
reflective than his
gray sweatshirt it existed then but it's
just just starting
which is high dynamic range imagery
basically having values
above white and below black on your
screen yeah hdri
was such a important feature of creating
cg because it allowed you to store the
values
that you know would help create the
realistic imagery of something that is
actually lit
with real light
it looks like they really did like a
wire pull on the character
it looks like a real character actually
yeah it does because the motion blur is
correct though yeah the camera's
tracking something so
barely and now it's like full cgs
comp tombstone what's wrong with it why
does it look
a little eh you know one cg uh
supervisor once told me
concrete doesn't bounce it's so heavy
and so when you see concrete kind of
bouncing like maybe it feels like a
little
styrofoamy but it's like the colors of
that thing too
is it just like direct lighting or
something on the shadows maybe it's the
soft shadows on the grass
that goes back to the high dynamic range
thing look at the tombstone on the left
look how bright
the parts facing upwards are versus the
parts in the front and look how
much less contrast you have in that
tombstone facing us it's still top lit a
little bit but that brightness between
the
light hitting the top of the tombstone
the front of the tombstone is just not
quite there
the classic composited explosion with no
smoke you get the hint of like
anamorphic lens flare in the beginning
of the explosion too if you look closely
does it look like the tree is actually
on fire so i wonder if
half of this explosion is real and
they've kind of added a secondary
element to make it look
more intense i would bet there's a
little bit of a real explosion buried
there under everything
you know it's a big budget movie it
makes sense they just ran out of money
for the tombstone budget
we need a new vehicle all right so a
street fighter movie came out none of
you have probably ever heard of it
sweet intro this is the climactic fight
of the entire
film by the way
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just wasted man i don't get hit by that
thing anytime you're dealing with
energy effects you're trying to convey
some kind of power
the problem perhaps is that it looks
very two-dimensional right so there's no
volume to it doesn't have form to it so
having volume would immediately give it
some depth and space right but there's
other things you might do like
having the light kind of flickering and
you know looking like
unstable right that might give it a
sense of power there actually is a
little bit of distortion but they're
doing something which i always try to
avoid which is
overlapping the image on top of itself
it's not a good idea to
blur things like that because a camera
would never create that effect a camera
would create like a heat distortion
like you see a jet near the horizon
you're gonna see this kind of distortion
where the image is blurred and then
maybe even
if her performance was maybe interacting
with the wave of the energy so it felt
like
it was being you know generated the
impact too i would say is you either
want it to be explosive
and create this huge shock wave that
bursts the energy out
maybe it runs through his whole body and
the electricity you know goes around him
there needs to be
an equal impact to the effect and this
feels like it does
maybe the worst thing which is it just
sort of fades out it's a pretty cool
stunt i mean the fall is pretty cool but
it just needed something
a satisfying explosion like at the death
star
it just started fades out yeah
oh man i always found that energy
effects are the toughest for me
personally just because there's not
too much reference i know there's
reference like you mentioned a few like
the jet distortion the heat distortion
and whatnot but it's like you get this
shot and it's like well
what do i reference people don't see
this every day what would you reference
for this
i mean whatever they reference i
wouldn't reference them
[Music]
okay okay all right andrew your vfx
supervisor
this is the shot that they just gave to
you and you have to give notes okay and
i can't reshoot it i just have to
fix the v effect somehow so first of all
that guy's dead
yeah he's in the freaking fire dude i
think the shot needs
more warmer tones in it and it should
feel like the light source is
more colored to the fire so even though
the fire is white it's really like a
warm color it's just blown out
and if the fire's that bright and this
close to us i think he should be much
more blown out
and more tinted kind of warm colored and
then maybe just
more fire or sparks kind of coming
underneath him to kind of make him feel
like he's more inside of it
yeah some foreground elements would be
great how do you feel about the roto job
here
if you pause it you can see like some
halo around the fingers and the arm and
stuff like that
i've seen these similar halos in the
movie ghost he's kind of got this
aura around him it's amazing molly
the love inside oh it's like intentional
halos
it's crazy like it sure looks nice like
they spent the money on the sets the
actors
just give your effects a little more
time hey if you enjoy watching this show
and you're not subscribed to the channel
we'd really appreciate it if you did
subscribe to the channel
so consider subscribing to quarter crew
all right andrew i think this is a clip
that you mentioned yeah yeah i stumbled
upon this
you know just thinking this whole car
chase is all realistic
and then come to find out in the behind
the scenes like that shot of the car
flying past the camera wait
wait wait that's a cg car yep
i shouldn't have said anything spoiled
it
but go ahead and watch it go ahead and
watch it this is some sick [ __ ]
yeah it's about to get sicker
so that would be a cg car right there it
came over the camera i wonder if it's a
real element
compton
there's another one yeah anytime a car
drives over the camera we just assume
it's cg is anything close to that
rolling car basically
so they would go film the real thing in
kind of an extreme
situation and try to match the weight of
the suspension
the way that the car actually moves oh
wow so it wasn't an element it was
actually full cg that's impressive
it's great that they shot this for the
vfx artist like this shows like a
professional crew
that treats visual effects as part of
the professional pipeline and not just
an afterthought
dude that's so cool so well done perfect
use of cg yeah i think the benefit of
doing a side-by-side comparison
is having that direct reference just so
that you are being able to look at left
and right say oh wait what's happening
here and i mean
honestly 2003 this is
super impressive yeah it's michael bay
man his stuff looks so good yeah i think
michael bay likes to create
very fantastic images and even if that
ferrari
is fake we're still flying past a real
car tumbling right towards a film camera
the shot is already fantastic and then
to say okay well look
it might save us a few bucks if we don't
crash the ferrari
maybe just once again it's a testament
of good practical work
it creates the motion it creates the
cinematography to drop a cg car in the
corner
we're not looking for it because usually
like the impossible moves would pull you
out like the car driving over the camera
that's so
non-spectacular compared to what's
happening here yeah that it doesn't even
trigger
response i mean i totally think of
matrix reloaded you know when trinity
turns around goes backwards on traffic
camera goes under the 18-wheeler
similar vibes and also too in baby
driver when he does that backwards
around down the alley it's like two cg
trucks you know so you do the stunt and
then you put the cg cars to make it seem
way more dangerous
pretty fun pretty fun that's a good
scene this is a really good find
[Music]
[Applause]
motion
so andrew is this a example of a good
vfx shot or a bad vfx shot in your
opinion here i feel like
there's one too many spins at the end
here yeah i feel like this is
an example of they maybe just took it a
little too far
it's a very ambitious shot they have the
technology and the skill i would just
say
it's the physics for me that throws it
off just enough that it kind of doesn't
feel so real
even though they've done a lot right for
me it's like contrast like
right at this point right here it's the
blacks are too
washed out maybe or the mid tones are
too washed out i think it could be part
of it is the
car paint shader it's the difference
between it looking kind of plasticky
you know versus here where see how shiny
those highlights of the light are
they're specular because the car is very
shiny and now when we go to the next
scene
the highlights aren't popping on the car
paint like they were in the real one
you can see it's still reflecting like
the spotlight on the ground but then
that zing
that the car paint has well let's look
at some of the things they did right
there's a lot to like about this look
the headlight goes off when it impacts
in the wall i think they did a good job
with the smoke
smoke looks nice there's like a
helicopter light kind of pointing down
on it and so you can actually see the
shadow
of the car in the helicopter light
seeing the bodies kind of bounce around
there maybe they're a little bright in
there
that it kind of stands out but they
didn't have to use a
convertible but the cg guy was like no
no it's all good
we do a convertible we got the ragdoll
simulation ready to go
i actually really think the sparks are
well done yeah hard to do good cg sparks
but
they got the bloom right on the sparks i
almost wonder if the sparks are real
because they look so good they have a
lot going on in this shot before being
done in 2001 but you have a person
deforming the fence you have the tires
if the sparks have the chunks you have
the smoke you have the lighting of the
spotlight if the people
and all those things added together you
need to have it all there for it to
really sell as being real
i feel like 2001 is right when really
well done cg was turning that corner
yeah
the rings came out around that time star
wars fan of medes came on 99 but so they
were kind of refining their things like
it was kind of getting to the point
where everybody was starting to figure
out okay these are the elements we need
to make something look good
and you only see it in like really
high-end movies and even then you know
it doesn't quite nail it but like you
got the level of detail and the
awareness of all the different processes
going on and to me that is a big point
it's the awareness like there's a lot of
ingenuity and cleverness that was put
into this shot from the way that the
wheel falls off and the destruction of
the scene around
it there's a lot of attention to detail
actually i noticed it looks like a pole
has stuck through the engine and the car
is dangling from
its engine block oh yeah i hate when
that happens
oh my god whoa i don't want to spoil it
but have you guys ever seen the movie
cliffhanger
she dies dang rough
it's one way to fall so i know we do a
lot of movies we do some tv shows and
all that kind of stuff in here
i'd really like to do a vfx artist react
to like
fan films and indie films and cool
projects done on youtube or just other
indie filmmakers out there
doing visual effects i'd love to do an
episode on that so please recommend
some shorts with really cool visual
effects that are on youtube in the
comments below
thank you hey i know what you're
thinking you might not be able to see
other people but you can still go
outdoors and what better shoes to wear
than a vessy let me tell you about these
things they're 100 waterproof and snow
proof they keep you cool in the summer
and warm in the winter
they're super easy to clean this pair is
the weekend pair and they're
machine washable they get dirty throw
them in the machine and wash them
not the dishwasher i made that mistake
too many times they're incredibly comfy
they're super lightweight i don't even
have to tie the laces they just go on
and off like that super easy it's truly
an everyday sneaker i wear these every
day into work
and the weekends on long drives because
they are really supportive on the heel
and they're very nice and squishy also
these are sustainably made they're vegan
so there's like no animal products in
here
they're very efficient with how they
weave the stuff together with the
knitting so
there's not that much material waste
either so if you guys want a pair of
these or any shoes from vestiges all you
gotta do is click the link in the
description and use the coupon code
corridor crew
and you will get 25 off your order
that's a sweet deal
all right now back to andrew kramer the
guy who taught me how to use after
effects
andrew thank you so much for joining us
man it really is an honor
and if you guys want to get into visual
effects yourself go to videocopilot.net
go through some tutorials there's like
150 160 odd tutorials
lots of cool plugins like vc console i
install windows and then i install
vc console but man thank you so much i
really appreciate you man
we always learn a lot when you come down
here appreciate it it's good to be here